I hope this is gonna be good the raid
redemption is about a SWAT team that is
infiltrating an apartment building owned
by this gangster this guy who's into
drugs and deceit terrible guy you get a
few scenes to establish this guy is the
scum of the earth
this SWAT team is infiltrating this
building with one goal take out all the
people find that guy bringing to jail if
possible take him out if need be and the
entire movie is essentially one gigantic
action scene with each floor being a new
level of chaos this movie stars a bunch
of people who are extremely good at
ripping off each other's faces kicking
punching stabbing shooting every little
thing could possibly think of flipping
dodging and the lead man in this movie
is pretty much the most ballsy person
who ever walked the planet and he is
amazing in this movie as is the fighting
in this movie holy crap I have not seen
action scenes this extensive in such a
long time this movie is a great ride the
action scenes in this movie are so
fantastic it's like okay we're gonna
infiltrate the building now suspense all
there's men with guns
okay shootout oh one this guy's just
came out of the wall okay fight this guy
really quick oh there's a room with like
20 people doesn't matter to fight them
all on whim these people are crazy good
stunt man this is one of the best action
movies I've seen in a while the action
is fantastic the choreography is
brilliant but there are a few things
that are wrong with this movie in my
opinion basically whenever the movie
tries to stray away from being an action
movie we get some shots of the main guy
at the beginning he's working out we
find out he's got a pregnant wife at
home okay we've seen that before it's a
cliche all right the scenes inside the
apartment building are suspenseful and
extremely exhilarating but whenever the
action stops and characters start
talking with one another about their
lives no I always like a little bit more
depth with my action movies I want to be
able to feel for these characters I
really didn't feel afraid of these
characters the action is amazing okay it
really is great but as for character
depth they're trying to flesh out the
characters not so much also there might
actually be too much action towards them
in that movie I was actually like wow
but seriously though this is a great
action movie I really really liked it
there is a lot of action it's really
well done extremely well choreographed
I'd recommend this movie for sure to
action film junkies to people who
kung fu movies it's just that if you're
looking for a movie where you can kind
of feel more depth and weight to the
people who are fighting that might be
disappointing to you however it's so
exhilarating and so cutting-edge and so
well filmed everything about the fight
scenes is so impressive that you kind of
look through that a little bit and just
view it as pure Pulp entertainment and
this film definitely delivers although I
don't know why the American title is the
raid redemption redemption has no point
to this movie at all I like the original
title the raid I'm gonna go there rate
of be plus it's a great action movie
it's a lot of fun add a lot of fun in
this movie do you guys have a favorite
kung fu movie mine's probably the matrix
in fact it's definitely the matrix I
don't come foo
stay tuned this week guys I'm going to
be putting up my Empire Strikes Back
review of the special skit starring Yoda
look forward to that and if you liked
this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck my eyes
[Music]